okay sometimes it's easy to get a false
sense of security as someone who knows
that we are in the United States legally
with an American passport I was born in
Argentina I came to the United States my
family had the visa lottery and when I
was seventeen years old because my
parents were citizens I was able to go
to the post office fill out a passport
application form and that made me an
American citizen so I have a level of
comfort when I'm talking to police
officers or people from border patrol if
I'm traveling down near the southern
border or whatever that is warranted in
the sense that I know I'm here legally
but at the same time it can be a false
sense of security we all the time hear
horror stories about migrants who are
detained for days without soap without a
toothbrush but we sometimes think it
could never happen to us because we're
here legally and then we hear about a
nine-year-old u.s. citizen
with her passport who was detained by
Border Patrol for 32 hours in March we
had one story last week like this of an
18 year old American citizen Francisco
Erwin Galicia who was determined by a
border patrol transferred to ice held
for three weeks even though he had
documents on his person that proved he
was born in Texas within four hours of
the Dallas Morning News reporting about
it Galicia was free the explanation it
was a so-called bureaucratic mix-up
regardless whether detainees do or don't
have American citizenship they shouldn't
be held without a shower for 23 days
like Galicia was its unamerican and it's
immoral and it is the antithesis of what
this country is supposed to be but it's
even worse we've now learned of a nine
year old girl who in March was detained
by Border Patrol for 32 hours even
though she was a US citizen I'm talking
about Julia Medina she's American her
family lives in mess at Mexico they
crossed the border to go to school each
day she and her 14 year old brother were
detained by Border Patrol she had her
passport
her butt Border Patrol said the picture
on the passport doesn't really look like
her she was questioned at nine years old
without her parents present when Border
Patrol was asked why did it take 32
hours to confirm her legal status as an
American citizen so far as of an hour
ago
Border Patrol has not had an explanation
Border Patrol tried to have Julia's 14
year old brother sign a document which
said actually julia is his cousin not
his sister insinuating some kind of
human trafficking angle to the entire
fiasco which of course is untrue it was
indeed his sister Border Patrol also
said Julia provided inconsistent
information during her questioning she's
nine years old did she first say Pete
says her favorite food and later said
that it's hotdogs she's nine years old
being questioned by law enforcement
without her parents eventually Julia's
mother was able to get the help of the
Mexican Consulate who contacted American
immigration authorities so I'm not
telling you this story to suggest that
this would be okay if Julia really
wasn't a citizen right this is a moral
crisis of the highest level no matter
what the nationality of the kids that
are being detained is what I'm trying to
point out to you is that first of all of
course this is hugely racially tinged
she's American with a passport but she's
non-white Hispanic crossing the border
from Mexico secondly if you're angry
about how she was treated realize that
it's just as bad for a nine-year-old
without an American passport to be
treated this way it's really easy for us
to sit back and not react strongly when
we're told listen a lot of these kids in
cages and kids being detained and
questioned by law enforcement with no
lawyers or parents a lot of them are
here illegally they're not American
citizens these are children
these are children they're not deciding
things for themselves if you are
horrified by this story of the
nine-year-old US citizen Julia Medina
you should be just as horrified by the
stories of non citizen kids as well
understand the gravity of the direction
that we are going here this
isn't just becoming a papers please
society that we're developing it's one
where even with the papers it doesn't
help you like it didn't help Julia
Medina
because apparently as a nine-year-old
based on the combination of her quote
inconsistent answers and coming over the
border and not looking like the picture
on her passport even then the papers
were not good enough to prevent a
32-hour detention of a nine-year-old by
immigration authorities I don't know
what the solution is here it I mean yes
it's obviously getting rid of Donald
Trump and changing the policy around a
lot of what is going on but that's not
the solution in and of itself that this
is a much bigger problem make sure to
follow the david pakman show on
instagram where we have a poll about
this issue at david pakman show on
instagram and while you're there follow
me at david pakman as well